when you hear the word socialism what do
you think of that is that a positive or
negative in your mind um right now I
think it is more of a positive
Millennials who are they what do they
believe why do we care we visited a
college campus to talk with some of
these young mysterious creatures who may
hold the keys to the country's political
future and we asked for some help from
Reason Foundation polling director Emily
Eakins who happens to be a millennial
herself go ahead and mock Generation
selfie all you want but ikan says
politicians and activists from all sides
of the spectrum dismissed the
Millennials at their own peril there are
three major reasons why we should care
about the Millennial Generation one
they're one of the largest generations
we've seen in American history - they're
very diverse and have a lot we have a
lot of new Americans in this generation
the third reason is that Millennials
came of a politically impressionable age
during the post 9/11 era with ballooning
government spending too unpopular Wars
and then the Great Recession these are
things that will forever impact their
political judgments in their voting
behavior even as they get older and as a
result we want to understand what they
think because that helps us understand
how our politics will change in the
future when they start to vote more how
do you describe yourself politically
liberal conservative something else no
I'm more liberal I think liberal I was
usually many more liberal but I guess it
depends on the topic I've grown up in a
very conservative household so um but
I've been open to a lot of liberal views
what we're finding is that young
Americans today are increasingly more
comfortable using the word liberal than
older Americans in fact they're twice as
likely to self-identify as liberal and
about half as likely to identify as
conservative I don't really have a
political affiliation but I guess if you
were to define it be a moderate between
liberal conservative money-wise I'm kind
of a moderate but social issues rising
pretty liberal a lot of people have
prematurely concluded that young people
are liberals and that's actually not
true they're not liberals they're social
liberals 62% self-identified as socially
liberal but only 49% said that they were
economically liberal so that average
millennial that average
you might talk to on the street it's
probably going to be a social liberal
and pretty moderate on the economic
issues do you prefer Democrats or
Republicans or nits neither I don't like
the two-party system there's things I
agree from one party that I don't agree
with the other and vice versa so I just
have to really kind of figure out which
one I'm more leaning towards right now
it's neither I'm kind of angry at both I
would I vote a Democrat before for a
bomb election but right now it just
seems like a big ol like party and
they're kind of working or conniving
together young people are three times as
likely as Americans over 30 to
self-identify as politically independent
a third of them saying no they don't
lean towards either of the two major
political parties both the Democratic
and Republican parties will need to take
note of young people Democrats may feel
that they kind of have the millennial
generation in their pockets and that is
not accurate why do you think that is
that people around this age just don't
trust either party um they get a lot of
their information on internet there's a
lot that comes to light so you can see
the inconsistencies well wellness at all
you know we're gonna get out of all
these wars we're gonna stop doing these
things a lot of people are like you know
that's that's a good idea you know we
don't need to be wasting our time and
battles that are pointless and then lo
and behold we're still doing all the
same thing so even though Obama said he
was going to try and take the chips out
I don't think that's enough young people
still like President Obama but they are
disappointed in him now he won the
election with 60% of the youth vote
however today only a slim majority about
51% they'll still say they approve of
his job performance but that doesn't
mean they're happy with everything that
is transpired during his administration
when you hear the word socialism what do
you think of that is that a positive or
negative in your mind um right now I
think of it as more of a positive
because it's like I think our country
could use it a little bit more for me
socialism I see it as a min between
because uh
is this portion of wealth in this
country people tend to have a negative
perception of it probably due to Russia
those kind of things but now I have no
negative connotation towards that it's
kind of a loaded term because you know
socialism can go anywhere from like you
know Stalinist Russia just to a country
like you know like Sweden or Norway you
know which is doing pretty well for
itself what's happening here is that
young people don't know what the word
socialism means a government managed
economy isn't even socialism that's
socialism light but if they were to
understand that socialism meant
government running Facebook Amazon uber
they would not like that would you like
to see the government or politicians
kind of making decisions about you know
who makes what products or do you think
that's best left to the market I think
that's best left to the market I guess
you know being born in the US in raised
here I'd I prefer free-market have a
positive view of entrepreneurs and small
business um for the most part yeah I
can't knock anyone for trying to get
their ideas off the ground because I
mean eventually I hope I could do
something like that
it is for a business that you want to
start um not right now it's just you
know I know I kind of want to start one
yet you put down ten grand you can get a
loan for that amount it started
franchise we have a great opportunity
where they'll just build the building
for you and you become an operator owner
that's one opportunity in America you
couldn't get that in say China young
people have a different language than
older people especially a different
political language and as a result
people should be as precise and specific
as possible when they talk about
politics not making big generalizations
about socialism or capitalism or big
government those things don't convey the
meaning that they used to they need to
be specific about what government is
doing how its doing it and who's paying
for it once young people learn that
they're paying for things that really
changes how they approach politics do
you think government spends money wisely
no I definitely don't think they spend
money wisely should take out money from
war
and put an inch our education military
industrial complex that kind of thing I
think they spent too much like I said in
the defense ministry like supporting
countries that maybe shouldn't be we
need to be more concrete when we talk to
young people and be specific in the
words that we use words like capitalism
and socialism language from the Cold War
post-world war ii era is just not going
to work because those words of lost
meaning